the Mexican Air Force flying high above
the center of the country heading into
battle with an enemy that's been hitting
these lands for the last three years
drought
they're taking Engineers from a private
firm startup Renaissance to deploy a
secret weapon that they hope will
literally Make It Rain
it's called cloud seeding it means
spraying particles of crystalline silver
iodine into clouds the water droplets
there are attracted to those particles
and cling around them that makes new
heavier drops heavy enough to fool as
rain
because we're constantly monitoring the
movement of clouds and checking if
they're in your target area that's when
we program flights
authorities been seeding in different
parts of Mexico since 2021 but the
target of this new program is the seven
reservoirs of the kutsamala water system
that's because these reservoirs through
the system deliver water into Mexico
City where there are chronic shortages
and the hope is that by cloud seeding
and Topping up their levels this one for
example is at one of its lowest Ebbs in
the last 25 years the water flow into
the capital will increase
cloud seeding is costing the Mexican
Government around twenty thousand
dollars per flight so there's a key
question does it work Air Force captain
and meteorologist Ricardo Torres has no
doubt
these operations which we have been
carrying out since 2021 in the north of
the country have increased rainfall from
25 to 40 percent
but sometimes scientists aren't
convinced
my opinion I have always said this is a
waste of money
this is a money pit they say they claim
that they have evaluation methods that
we question very much I don't think
their evaluation methods are valid and
the other thing is with the very little
information we have
we know that the dams that the the
dancing in body de Bravo and the the
kutsamala system the three dams have not
been refilled at all
the engineers in the program and
scientists agree on is that cloud
seeding alone is not a silver bullet
that will solve Mexico City's water
shortages
the capital's infrastructure is too
deteriorated for that at least a third
of its water is already lost within old
leaking pipes and it treats and recycles
just a fraction of its sewage
no amount of these expensive flights are
going to fix those big structural
problems
John Holman Al Jazeera via Victoria
Reservoir Mexico